today five home cooks put their skills
on the line in a frenzied cooking clash
but only one can take home $2,000 first
prize and the title culinary genius
[Music]
[Applause]
to culinary genius so they say too many
cooks spoil the broth but we think five
is just about the right number to take
part in our demanding cooking contest
today's contenders each have brought
their favorite item from their home
kitchen to help them and Gordon Ramsay
we'll be giving them tips too but to win
culinary genius our contestants have to
win over a king of the kitchen Edward
Lee all right so what are you expecting
from these fabulous contestants today
today we're actually testing our cooks
knife skills ooh
now the three sharpest chefs will go on
to the next round why I have a pantry
full of ingredients from China the
Middle East and France so let's reveal
today's ingredient
contestants please lifter cloches it's
sweet potatoes before Edward sets
today's challenge let's get some hints
on this versatile vegetable from Gordon
Ramsay right today you'll be cooking
with these bad boys these are the new
super foods it is the incredible sweet
potato now the average American eats 20
large sweet potatoes a year and for me
from a chess point of view the most
important thing we can cook savory and
sweet what would I do with this I turn
into the most amazing sweet potato pie
finish with Carol I speak ons and I know
sweet potatoes are a big staple in
southern cooking so Edward what will you
be doing with these sweet potatoes today
thanks Gordon all right cooks today I
want you to cut this sweet potato into
very thin matchsticks the first thing we
want to do is square it off we'll take
the top portion off put it in your bowl
take the other half put it away now
we're gonna take this we're gonna stand
it up now you're gonna try and make a
square so one side up next side off
there 90 degrees and try and make a
perfect square
now that you have this square cut
lengthwise to form long even spices
don't cut your fingers pull your finger
tips in using that first knuckle of your
middle finger as a guide for your knife
this is what we call the claw line it up
and go right down you see what I'm doing
you want them as evenly sized as
possible when you have enough the last
one discard that now you want to cut
these into matchsticks grab a little
stack like that and start yeah
using that knuckle as your guide let
your knife do the work there you have it
will you take this transfer it right
onto your cutting board they should all
be exactly the same size one more time
arrange them nicely use your knife
transfer them onto your presentation
board they're all the same size they're
all the same thickness they're all the
same length this is what I'm looking for
back to your stations Thanks so Edward
is going to judge on the quantity as
well as the quality of the matchsticks
you have five minutes on the clock at
the culinary battle begin
[Music]
Edward what is your favorite way to cook
with sweet potato well we do at the
restaurant we actually spoke this week
potatoes first and then we make a
beautiful purée out of it a little bit
of ginger a little bit of red onion
let's see how they're doing yeah
hi there Susan how's it going so far
well I was brought up eating sweet
potatoes with my grandmother I think was
her favorite thing to cook so I am
thinking very much of horrible all right
well good luck cut on carefully thank
you very much
Tiffany how you doing did it have you
finding this challenge oh it's fine yeah
good you're listening to me about the
cloth what'd you bring from home
I brought some oyster sauce is it a
homemade oyster sauce no okay hope you
get to the next round
Thank You Maria hello there all right Oh
lots of matchsticks going on there and I
see that you cooked some corn tortillas
yes and you have sweet potato in those
tortillas no I grew up actually eating
them with sugar and cinnamon so it's
very very different but I like them
roasted actually so see what happens
well good luck thank you
Sara how you doing I'm doing all right
you got two kids at home I do you do a
lot of fast chopping and dicing ever I
do and my kids love sweet potatoes it
was the first food both of my children
ate so and I loved him as well I've
eaten them all my life
savory and sweet looking forward to it
great hello there Chris checking in on
your match sticks are you sweet potato
fan oh yes I love sweet potatoes
especially around Thanksgiving with
marshmallows on top and brown sugar
those are so delicious
totally all right well good luck thank
you very much all right so what Tiffany
wasting a lot so I hope she has enough
on the board
Sara's not she doing okay she's got some
kids at home she cooks for so she's
doing all right Susan now she's making
really fat matchsticks I've never seen
matchsticks so big ten nine
thank you check every with their knifes
those bite only three can make it
through to the final culinary round so
it's time to find out what Edward thinks
of their sweet potato matchsticks let's
check them out all right Tiffany so I'm
gonna go through this doesn't count you
did pretty good you were slow starting
out but you finished strong let's see so
you got about that much okay first I'm
doing it yep yeah very good I'm gonna
put this together pretty good amount you
had one like thinner pile and one
thicker pass I think between the two
sweet potatoes you kind of messed up a
little bit there but still not bad
thank you Wow Susan you got a lot done
that's a lot of sweet potato but but I
got a lot of inconsistency here look at
that yeah right that's not a matchstick
that's a toothpick overall you did
really well but they don't all match so
let's see how the others did now yours
is very thin Wow
that's not gonna work okay so you have a
lot of trim here a lot of inconsistency
all right no there Chris time of truth
yes
nice presentation most of yours are
pretty good good job thank you much nice
presentation Chris all right now it is
time for our chef to tell us who has
done what it takes to get through to the
final
[Music]
the first contestant going through to
the final is Chris second contestant to
go through is Tiffany the third and
final contestant to go through is Susan
Chris Tiffany and Susan you are going
through to the final that means that the
show ends here today for Sarah and Maria
a thousand dollars and the title of
culinary genius awaits one of today's
three finalists now to create their dish
they have been given duck and they have
the option of using the sweet potatoes
that they prepared in round one so
entered what are you looking for so in
front of you you have a beautiful luxury
ingredient I want you to cook the best
dish you've ever cooked in your life and
I want that to happen right now okay now
to stock up on your ingredients you have
two minutes on the clock so make sure
you check out the fridge - while you're
there your time starts
[Music]
what is our range of ingredients in the
pantry today well we've got so many
fruity things to go with that rich duck
so we've got pomegranates
we've got cherries we've got
blackberries but we also have things
like bok choy and spinach
there's lime leaves there's thyme
rosemary cinnamon and in the fridge we
have Greek yogurt feta and pancetta YUM
one minute one minute remains there's
all these ingredients I don't know what
to do so I just try to grab a little bit
of everything so think about what you
want to pair with a very rich fatty
piece of duck what do I do with that cuz
I've never cooked it before so I'm
thinking to do something quite fruity
and fresh as well we're not filling you
for this you can pick whatever you want
I don't think you need too many
ingredients just a good balance
[Applause]
you now have 25 minutes to produce the
best duck dish of your lives let the
battle hello there Tiffani what did you
grab from the pantry what is the sauce
this is oyster sauce what do you like to
usually cook with it Oh everything great
salt eats yeah I'm trying to discuss if
everything's sure does oh you're using
this in your dish yes I don't see a lot
of other things other than spices and a
couple of sauces so you don't have a lot
to work with
so think creatively about how you can
mix this all together okay Susan hello
there alright I want to do a roast duck
with a blackberry sauce I've never
cooked duck before I don't even know if
I've eaten duck before if you haven't
cooked with duck before take a slice try
it before you start putting your
concoctions together right okay I really
don't know how it should taste I just
hope it's nice you've got a lot going on
here you just got to figure out how it's
gonna combine on the plate all right
Kristen is fun colorful shirt you're
gonna make us a colorful duck oh yes I
am I'm trying to think of something that
I've always do at home like deep-fry
some oil fry some stop and then make
mashed sweet potatoes and some spinach
with bacon and maybe some bok choy I may
have grabbed too many things but I have
this ideal in my head that I know I will
execute perfectly I know Edward here
loves whiskey so I'm gonna try to put
that in my sauce as well whiskey and
duck we'll find out if that's genius
what I want you to do is you brought a
lot of ingredients from the pantry yes
don't get confused by it be smart about
how you compose your dish okay thank you
sir all right
Tiffany is doing I duck with oyster
sauce and garlic and then broccolini on
the side I want to make sure that she's
got something else on the plate that
kind of elevates it Susan's doing a
roast duck with blackberry sauce a nice
move because obviously a fruit and duck
what a natural pairing that is that's
we're going to Chris the only thing that
I worry about is that he's got a lot of
ingredients on his pantry and then
you've got too many flavors on a plate
what would you have picked for the
pantry to cook today I would do a really
nice five spice rubs duck render off
that skin make it real crispy a sweet
potato puree with some fresh ginger in
it and then maybe cherries cook them a
little bit of brandy and just kind of
make a nice little cherry sauce around
the plate beautiful all the contestants
need to realize that they need to render
off some of that fat and give me a
crispy skin I do not want just a thick
layer of goopy fat Oh their kitchen know
how to get Edwards seal of approval for
their delicious duck so I'm gonna go
check it all out Susan hello there what
is your normal kitchen style what do you
like to cook I like to cook French
dishes I like to do a lot of ethnic I
like Mexican food because I'm from New
Mexico I'm just a lot of different
things sometimes Moroccan Spanish as
well
rocking if thousand dollars is a nice I
would like to use it for holiday to
Croatia you love all the exotic
locations hello Tiffany
tell me what's going on in your mind
right now you're like it's not cooking
fast enough in the audience right yeah a
little supporter here today yeah like
Beyonce's hair your fiancee
congratulations can you give her some
words of encouragement it's always
delicious so I know you can do it
and you have some Vietnamese influence
to your cooking style at home right tell
me about that it's mom always cooked
every meal we add that together so I
just kind of learned from her what to
make what would it mean to you to be
named culinary genius See Mom I can't
cook it's always about mom
thanks Tiffany hey there Chris how you
doing wonderful alright so I know you're
a dad of two you your kids just love
that you are such a great chef they do
we lived in Japan for a few years so at
least once a week Leigh I try to make
Japanese curry what are your kids at
chocolate gravy and biscuits for
breakfast alright those are some lucky
kids that start the day with the
chocolate yeah I know you're putting
your best efforts forward here good luck
thank you very much
you're almost done you got a five
minutes left
what's inside your song that is why
brace off because honey it has some star
nice okay and it has some orange and
ginger in it as well can I give you a
hint yeah taste good chef please have my
sauce tastes nice abouts a good sign I'm
just hoping it all comes together when
you present it we make it look pretty
for me I will do my very best for you
Tiffany I need you to move a little bit
you're like a statue over here I was
your duck doing okay I hope so I really
wanted to cook my broccolini with the
rendered duck fat which why I was
standing there for so long that's how
your mom cooks in the kitchen
well usually should point since she's
like you do that okay well then you're
gonna have to do the point again imagine
you're you know your mom is right here
right now I'm your mom we're just
looking right down at you and I'm
criticizing does that help you is that
completely something fun okay thank you
Chris what's that method I've never seen
ahead well because I took it out of the
oven a little too early so I figured I
would cut it in half I do try to make it
up as I go along it's not ideal but all
right make sure listen
make it pretty huh see what we could do
less than two minutes Tiffany still
hasn't moved from the frying pan I need
to get her inspired somehow Susan I know
she's cooking that duck for the first
time but don't be nervous we all do it
Chris I'm worried about this new
technique of splitting stuff in half and
cooking it and roasting it back it's
I've never seen that before where it is
time for Edward to judge what our cooks
have created so let's check them out
looking at my final dish I'm very
nervous but I am pleased with a color in
the presentation of it that looks good
I hope my duck is cooked I'm a little
nervous about that looking down at the
final dish I feel exhilarating it's
going to be amazing
nice colors I like that you got a lot of
presentation on this plate a little bit
worried about the duck might be
overcooked just a touch I'm gonna dig
right into the mayonnaise first
leave that though huh nice all right
nice mayonnaise and I don't know if you
notice but I love manners oh okay
so what I want to see on duck when you
cook it is a little bit of pink in the
middle you know you do have a little bit
but a little bit more would be nice
because you can see how over here where
it's actually turning gray and brown and
that's not gonna taste very good but you
can save it with a good sauce okay
your sauce was terrific thank you really
bright I can taste the spice in it very
nice and if you take nothing away from
this
that's fatty rich dense duck and that
bright fruit just like our perfect
together they're like marriage made in
heaven your sides may be a little bit
lackluster but the duck and that sauce
just brilliant really like that seeing
as how you took about 22 out of your 25
minutes to cook the duck I'm expecting
something very good out of the duck and
I will say look you got really beautiful
even caramelization on that skin it
looks very nice the broccolini is plated
very pretty
first I want to see how this duck so
that is a beautifully cooked duck
clearly something from your mother
rubbed off on you because that is a
perfectly cooked up it's really amazing
moisture sauce is really salty and so
you just need a little balance you know
a little bit of that fruit from the
pinch it would have been nice just to
kind of play along with it okay good job
though hey listen mom don't be so hard
on her she's amazing I like the way you
browned the duck skin a little bit your
sauce is a little bit runny you could
have thickened it up with a little bit
of butter maybe a little bit of flour
it's going for taste oh is this the duck
that you need a little flappy thing with
them I've never seen that before in my
entire life but you got a nice color on
it the duck is cooked nicely
just a touch overdone the sauce very
delicious I love your bacon and spinach
I wish that skin was more caramelized
because it's just really flabby the
flesh was nice and your spinach was
beautiful and your sweet potato worked
thank you Edward has made his decision
and decided who wins the thousand
dollars and of course the title culinary
genius
[Music]
to reveal today's winner finalists
please lift your cloches it was your
sauce and your mayonnaise that wanted
for you absolutely brilliant
congratulations thank you